start from the beginning
yo Bizzle click like it's show time is
it some type of prank call sign this
ain't no pranks we boy this is pretty
much UK live and directing your face
click like hey sprinkle if you wanted to
play with a big hard toy then you should
have just asked you know I was just
joking in it shut up you [__]
when I run into your home allow it
painting Alexa stop the music fan sorry
fam click clack
we're gonna need some more soldiers I'm
gonna call my man a minute if I ain't
got time for your CBBC man in blood this
time you do something that's gonna
finally put us on the map give me
everything you've got Pals 10 P's five
piece and even the brown pennies
you want the pennies stop me and my
type
on the phone
is
it all day midday I love them
you are beautiful hold on
hello I can't you see this he's a double
yellow light
what you're not saying what the [__] man
that's nasty can you not do that
allow it waste
[Music]
man who is we go quick hat it's Rico and
Kate
try to lock me up like some cage animal
they say 12 Years a Slave Kazi this is
some motherhood
your boobs don't smell like they used to
sleep
I'm trying to watch Jungle Books